but we were very clear that um
finally the tory party concluded that
boris johnson was unfit to be prime
minister that was blindingly obvious a
very long time ago but having come to
that conclusion they can't now expect
the country to allow to cling on for
weeks on end and so it's very important
we said that if they're not going to
remove him themselves it looks like
they're not then we would step up in the
national interest and bring this vote of
no confidence and frankly any tory that
in the last few days has said uh they
don't think the prime minister's fit for
office because he can't tell the truth
he can't be trusted how can they
tomorrow go through the lobby to say he
should stay in power for another few
weeks so you do you so it's symbolic
it's about politics it's not you don't
really think that you're going to win
the vote of no conflict i think it's
very important that we step up and take
whatever steps we can to remove him from
office he's unfit for that office the
reason that he is leaving office is
unlike previous prime ministers where it
was a policy disagreement he's leaving
office because his own party have
concluded that he can't be trusted that
if they go out on media with lines those
lines are going to unravel because they
haven't got the substance of truth
behind them that is intolerable for the
for the country as we go into the next
weeks into september and you talked
about i think it was zoe from sunderland
in your speech yesterday and how her
electricity and gas bills are doubling
and the boss of off gym yesterday said
the bills are actually going to be even
higher come october and one analyst
cornwall insight said 1200 pounds a year
higher than they were in april
she'll be wondering what would what
would labour do for me what would a
labor government do for me how would
they help well for many people this will
be absolutely on their minds you know
lots of people can't make ends meet at
the moment really struggling with their
bills
if those prices go up again and it looks
like they will then that's going to
cause even more anguish on this issue
labour is led from the front so we were
out there very early at the turn of the
year saying there should be a windfall
tax tax the excess profits from oil and
gas companies and use them for the
energy bills of those most in need the
government was slow so slow on that
refused to see why that was such a good
idea finally came to it we still think
there's other things they should do
shouldn't be introducing and having the
national insurance tax hike in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
and frankly what we need is an emergency
budget to look at those price rises and
put in place the support package that is
needed what you're not hearing by the
way from any of the tory candidates is
any practical measures to address the
cost of living crisis they're in this
fantasy world of spending commitments
330 billion pounds of spending
commitments when they can't say where
the money is going to come from and i
think for millions of people who are
going to struggle this autumn they'll be
looking at this circus of tory
contenders
baffled as to whether they live in the
real world so you'd introduce an
emergency budget but to a lot of people
they'll still be wondering well what
does that mean i mean would you commit
to cutting v80 on energy bills getting
rid of the green levy that kind of thing
well we do think cutting energy vat on
energy bills is the right way forward we
don't think the national insurance
attack should have been put in place and
an emergency budget will be an
opportunity to deal with that there are
other things that need to be done um
insulating homes is desperately overdue
that would reduce bills significantly
for millions of people across the
country if that was put in place so
there are practical things that can be
done
but unfortunately we've got a government
that is you know absolutely asleep at
the wheel now dysfunctional
and
you know millions of people who are
struggling with their bills will be
looking at what's going on um you know
with bewilderment a real alarm that
you've got a group of wannabe tory
leaders i'm not even talking about the
single most important issue facing the
country we've heard from a lot of senior
uh labour labour members over the past
few days peter mandelson and so forth
that have said
now is the time that labour needs to
define who it is that for for
the time of defining yourself as not
boris johnson is over boris johnson will
be leaving shortly
are we going to hear some real concrete
policy proposals from labour soon with
detail yes grow the economy reboot the
economy
rebuild re-energize our public services
which are broken and unite the country
that is the mission of an incoming labor
government and that's why we need not
just change at the top of the
conservative party this circus that's
going on at the moment we need something
much more fundamental than that um we
need a fresh start for britain
under a labour government so we need a
change of government so we're very clear
build that economy grow the economy it's
the single biggest failure of this
government over 12 years
fix our broken public services and unite
our country no more of this divisive
politics are we going to hear how how
that all happens well i set that out in
a speech yesterday in harrogate what we
would do to grow the economy we've got
the climate investment pledge we've got
the skills agenda we've already put put
in place buy make sell in britain that's
a policy we unveiled at conference last
year so there are many things to support
that growth agenda we're very clear on
public services we want preventative
medical models for health for mental
health for crime and we need to bring
the country together
so more no more of this divisive
politics ending the era of toxic
division